arriving for the main set piece of this
trial and of his broader battle with the
British press Harry's evidence began in
the form of a written statement in which
he said the Press had decided early on
to portray him as a thicko and a drug
user attempting to ruin his
relationships he made a huge departure
from Royal convention on staying out of
politics writing on a national level our
country is judged globally by the state
of our press and our government both of
which I believe are at rock bottom he
goes on to mention his distress at
various stories stretching from his
school days to his twenties such as what
he called his stupid decision to dress
as a Nazi for a fancy dress party in
2005 resulting in a telling off on the
phone by his then-girlfriend Chelsea
Davey he asks how could journalists have
known about it if not for phone hacking
and he said the distress caused by
journalists stories could lead to
Suicide asking how much more blood will
stain their typing fingers before
someone can put a stop to this madness
but in court Harry was repeatedly
challenged by the lawyer for Mirror
group newspapers Andrew Green KC he
implied that the prince was motivated by
hostility towards the British press and
questioned how he could have been
distressed by stories that he couldn't
confirm having read at the time and he
probed the prince for evidence that the
33 specific stories before the court had
been obtained unlawfully more than once
suggesting the information was already
in the public domain when challenged
that he didn't own a mobile phone at the
time of one alleged phone hacking
incident Harry suggested his mother
Princess Diana's phone may have been
hacked instead Mr Green responded that's
just speculation that you're coming up
with now Harry also pushed back
frequently suggesting the journalists in
question rather than he should be
challenged about the methods they used
there are a lot of other claimants that
lie behind this case as well this is a
test case and then there's three more to
go so yeah there's a lot of risk for him
in in taking this whole uh agenda if you
like into the courtroom rather than
settling as so many have done
so you're right you're right after
nearly five hours of testimony Prince
Harry made his way out to his car in the
knowledge he'd be back for more on
Wednesday
so a grueling difficult day of
cross-examination for Prince Harry by a
lawyer who treated him as a hostile
witness rather than a royal but also an
opportunity taken by the prince to lay
out his case against the British press
with more detail than ever before Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera London